today at 3:00 p.m. I was gonna get a the
the rattlesnake logo the thick boy look
on my why because when I'm riding can
see it so you know it's the thick boy
I'm so sick of all the people on thick
boy on the trail so I want start your
own company the hanging on the trail
store not gonna share your own company
you know I should get one terrible visit
well so but I was getting you the snake
on my quad on my thigh right today at
3:00 p.m. and then oh do you not though
because your tattooers is gonna be
indicted for murder so and I text them
when we get this show it hey man wait i
assuming we're not on for 3 p.m.
why is my tattoo it's the dime piece on
the left we were just talking about him
a couple weeks back yeah I got a tattoo
if you go to his Instagram and the last
[ __ ] guy you got a tattoo it go to
his Instagram yeah but it should be
manslaughter because I was talking to
Jay - between Jay goes if he just gets a
good lawyer it's gonna be manslaughter
but I still do some time there I am
there I am there there I am now he has a
mclaren 570s 7 20s but regardless he was
drinking drinking with fellow youtuber
and they ran into a tree okay I know he
broke his hip he was drinking so he was
very drunk when he got in the car we
don't know you just can't do that yeah
but you can't you shouldn't go to go to
prison it's it you it's it's
manslaughter Eric can be murder you can
go to jail for murder
yes but B if work let's say and I don't
know how it works but it doesn't seem
right to me say we you and I both get
drunk I'll find the kid you know Brian
and you go hey dude let's go let's go to
the gym you drive to the gym and I Drive
and I wreck and you die just your heart
like what I'm doing real fast you die
crashing you die casual and then I
survived I'm flourishing do I get hey
she's heading this up do I go to prison
for murder
I think you're insulting me while I get
in for murder even though we both agreed
weights that we're both so give me some
we're both intoxicated your brother go
hey Brennan can you drop me off from
whee-ha get some work to do are you sure
dude and so we drive to WeHo and yeah
like all excited yeah you got spray
geing bones why would I have a boner I
don't
doing working out your dick I know
you're we hope okay so I'm jacking it
you're jack you will kind of just like
how much money you made Marissa yeah you
like I can't wait to get in there I'm
like all right dude I'm just gonna drop
you off please don't ejaculate
okay so we're driving but we're both
drunk we've both agreed to jump in the
vehicle yeah I crash on our way to we
home even though we're both under
consent it's not manslaughter it there
are people doing life right now for
getting into a car being drunk and
killing somebody in another car no
different different we didn't we didn't
hit a bystander you we both agree begin
this vehicle intoxicated so so you can
now if you kidnap them I understand that
it feels like you're Gillick are dumping
you I crash you you can absolutely be
indicted for murder and convicted it's
just like this if you if you do a crime
with someone the crime person the person
who gets you the car the car the guy
steals the car and then even if he's not
in the car and you go off and kill
somebody that guess I'm in jail
you can be indicted for murder too so
you're all part of a murder conspiracy
you're all part of the murder right so
there have been people that you know get
complete farming uses you can do for
manslaughter 10:00 a.m. at 6 to 11 years
hold on probation with up to 1 year or 3
or 6 or 11 so if you can get
manslaughter and do he got pretty face
he could do 15 years pretty face now
here's tip for this video 15 years
guaranteed under 15 I don't know if
intoxicated I bet you he gets I bet you
get the year with a really good lawyer I
guess it depends on what he said to the
cops it depends on how was broken and
they did it they did a blood alcohol
test on the the tragic wall this is the
25 year old that died on it all right
that's that's a huge trash is horrible
25 year old kid no and you know that
what they're doing they're drinking like
a couple of idiots they did a very dumb
thing and sometimes it turns out that's
why does I never ever drink and drive
just you can't do it and and everybody
has done it
everybody has driven buzzed once in
their life or 10 times in their life
or 40 or 40 and every time you do that
you're taking someone else's now have I
seen it's out now Daniel the prison
system especially a little harsh
you're not fighter your pretty boy you
just seen the movie get hard it's an
issue I can be you're Kevin Hart it's
Annie hi Kevin Hart I can show you the
way I could use you in there he could
you could use the question is he's half
Brazilian yes the question is why
centered white or is he considered oh
you're full like a nation no you're full
Aryan Nation yeah yeah you just lie and
I can we background I'll tell you what
it's a nightmare on spending levels for
him I'm sure he's not a bad guy he
killed his friend he's nice he's dude
first of all I think he's 23 okay he's a
young kid that started business in San
Francisco wanted more for his life so he
came to LA became one the biggest tattoo
artist when you go to jail he's gonna be
doing tattoos you know that he'll be
doing everybody's tattoo jailhouse
tattoo he'll be fine yeah he'll be fine
but I mean not fine because he killed
his friend which is a decision which he
has to live with for the rest of his
life man I'm sorry about that all the
way around
stupid [ __ ] snake tattoo on your
thigh which I you know sighs you'd do
things like that and I go like this I go
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]